いつになったら離島にベスを買うんですか
うーん気が向いたら買いますこんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
タクシーで日本列島
横断したら何円かかるのー
今から
久々に
富山に帰ります
車が
というわけで私はじめしゃちょー出身が
富山県ということで実家が富山県にあるん
ですよで今日ですね久々に富山県に帰ろう
と思ったんですけどもふっとふと私思って
しまいました富山県から
静岡県よく見ると日本列島
横断してるんですよそして私気づきました
オレンジ海つまり静岡の海から富山の海に
行くと
地質日本列島横断してるんですよという
わけで富山県に帰るついでにとある実験が
できないかということで
タッチで日本列島をオーダーしたら何円
かかるか今日は検証していきたいと思い
ますそして今回お世話になるタクシー
こちらそして運転手さんがあちらに見えて
おります
すごい距離ですよろしくお願いします
まずの9時半の
朝の9時半から出発していきたいと思い
ますなんとなくの予想言っていい俺東京
から静岡帰った時なんか10万ちょい手前
ぐらいだった気がするんですけど多分ま
30万ぐらいとかじゃないですかね分かん
ないけどというわけで早速日本列島大猿
タクシーの旅行ってきます
ちょっと申し訳なさあるけど心地よく受け
てくださったタクシーのデジタさんがいた
んで莫大なフットキャクトだと思って
いただきたいよしじゃあ行ってきますわー
いってらっしゃいません
こっからずっとタクシーでしょすごいよ
じゃあ行ってきますや
ばいやいやいるんよ
変わりますよ
すごいすごいすごいお願いします
行ってきまーす
[拍手]
よろしくお願いします
これが太平洋側なかなか逆側のみに行く
ことないと思うんでちょっと貴重な経験
ですねこれはこのお話を聞いた時はどう
思われましたか
いや正直あのそんな遠くまで行くとは思わ
なかったものですね
あんまりいないですか富山までというか
ないですね
岐阜まで行ったことあったんですけれども
岐阜ですかそれでそれもでも結構遠いです
今ずっと長時間のお付き合いになると思う
んですけどよろしくお願いいたします
よろしくお願いします
そろそろ高速ですね
ちなみに今のところあピッタリやちょうど
6000円だちょうど6000円ですまあ
ある程度の長距離だったら多分6000円
ぐらいでまあまあまあってなるんですよ
タクシーは
まだ
高速ばかりですここからどう金額が伸びて
いくのでしょうか
[音楽]
はいというわけであっという間に山梨県に
入りました
すごいのも1時間ちょいで山梨まで来れ
ましたね
大自然
[音楽]
でちょっと待っててくださいはい了解です
ねお願いしますはいよろしくお願いします
すいませんもう一度お聞きしてもいいん
ですけどごめんなさい
[音楽]
ありがとうございました失礼いたします
読みました
すいませんちょっとでかい声で喋っちゃっ
て
2時間
ちょい経ちましたもうすぐ山梨県も小出
長野県に入りそうです
お戻らなかった
長野県に入ったところ料金が
[音楽]
まあまあまあまあまあまあまだまだ大丈夫
ですまだ大丈夫です
トイレとか大丈夫ですか大丈夫ですかそう
する中間地点なのでその前ぐらいに1回
サービスエリアで中継というか大量休憩し
たいと思います
もうすぐ4万円どうも長野県にいるんです
けども今多分
ちょうど中間ぐらいの場所にいますあと
ここからはあの
料金ちょっと最後に見たいんであのみない
ようにします最終的には何円いくの
でしょうかパッと見たらえー
4万2000円でした
もう
すぐ諏訪湖のサービスエリアですあと3
キロぐらいかな
[音楽]
ありがとうございました
ちょっとお姉さんもちょっと休んで
ください
すいません
それが
世に諏訪湖ですね
めっちゃでけえな箱まだお昼早いんで
トイレ休憩だけして
すぐタクシーも乗ろうと思いますまだ
寒いな中のは寒いなまだ
運転手さんもトイレ行ってます安心安心
ちょっとあの無理だけさせたくないないや
もう無理させてんだけど3
長野さん
静岡と北陸だと全然温度差があるなもう
山の上でしょほぼはい現在地っていうと
諏訪湖まさに
本当に今中間地点ぐらいですね
静岡と岩瀬ハマー海水浴場っていうところ
がゴール地点の予定なのでこんな感じに
離れております中のもうちょいやるんで
行きましょうか
[音楽]
なんやかやであと4割ぐらい結構来てます
ねはいというわけでここで高速を降ります
高速乗り続ける
ルートもあるんですけどそれだと新潟行っ
てちょっと遠回りになるんで下道で行った
方がなんかまっすぐ行けるんで今回の企画
は横断ということで下道でもいいの
ちょっとなるべくこうまっすぐ行く感じの
ルートで行かせていただきますよろしくお
願いします
[音楽]
運転手さんちょっと
疲れました
大丈夫ですか
何買ったら言ってくださいねありがとう
ございます
さすがに長すぎるんでちょっと
心配になってきましたあと3時間くらいは
マジちょっとどっかで休みましょう1回
ちょっと本当に申し訳ないですお腹すき
ました
本当ですかはい
無理してますか
道が険しいですね
初めてタクシーで峠攻めてる今の雪がある
県来ましたかね
[音楽]
車が倒れてますね車が倒れてるうわっどう
どうやって大丈夫かそして
中の人が
中に人がいるのかもしれないですね
ちょっとわかんないですけど
[音楽]
すみません
いやー
すごいなでも無事でよかったあそこで
片付けとけばこう通行でとりあえず行け
そうですのでね
すごいなぁ
[音楽]
めっちゃ可愛い
なんて可愛いんだ
岐阜県の道の駅到着しましたここで
ちょっと昼食
食べましょう
[音楽]
どう
ですか
美味しいです
[音楽]
引き続きよろしくお願いしますお墓も
服で出だし
最高だ
[音楽]
来たーマガジン戻ってやがて今
入りましたー
結構久々に地元に帰ってきました
富山県の端っこ
富山県の海ですね日本海側の海まで行く
までが今回の横断の企画なのでこのまま
実家には
帰りませんまずは海を見に行きます
どうですか海から海へ運転した
感想は
いい
経験でしたが疲れました
すいませんあまり遠くまで当たっていうの
はよほどの緊急事態じゃない限りそうです
よね全然緊急事態じゃないのにいやー
すごかった色々ハプニングもあったけど
すごいなんかいい運転したんでね
おー
海っぽくなってきた
あーてか海だ海だ
あ
めっちゃ綺麗この長旅もいよいよ終わりか
すげー
夕日が眩しいぜ
ついに到着ですか
富山の海到着ですお疲れ様でした
ということで運転したありがとうござい
ました本当にありがとうございました
ありがとうございました僕は何もしてない
ですけど
すごい達成感があります
非常に楽しかったですあ本当ですか
ありがとうございましたというわけで気に
なる
お会計よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
9万7620円になります
9万7620円
え10万切ってます
やって
本当だいやいや見たことないこの数字で
この下のこれは何ですかオレンジ色になり
ます
遠距離割引
長距離のお客さんの割引の
金額になりますここから引いていただける
とそうです
[音楽]
中盤切ってるんだ
高いな高いけど全然なんか思ったほどじゃ
なかったですもっとなんか20万ぐらい
いくかなと思っていつも僕は行かないと
思います
50万自分で来たんですけどてことは高速
代含めると10万いってそうだないやどう
なんだろう日本
横断
場所には寄るかもしれませんけども静岡
富山って結構膨らんでて
山道も多い場所でも10万切ってるって事
は大抵日本横断すると多分10万切るん
じゃないかなって気はしましたわからん
けどね全然ちょっと抽選からでお願いし
ますはい
高速代含めても
9万3130円どっちにしろ10万円切っ
てましたそうなんだこれまた1つ
わかったことだなすごい
テーマの上に静岡ナンバーのタクシーが
開けっ放しで
買ったピザのお土産なんですけどぜひ
なんかもらった
本当にありがとうございましたありがとう
ございました
どうもありがとうございました
すいません
こうしてはじめしゃちょーと運転手の
タクシーの旅は終わったまた一つ謎が
明らかになった
余談ですがこの後すぐタクシーの運転手は
静岡に帰りました
[音楽]